sitting high above the beach or pool and
responsible for saving lives lifeguards
are literally looked up to that's made
it a coveted job for generations of
Americans but lately economic forces
have turned the tide once again this
year lifeguards are in short supply
threatening all kinds of summer fun
at least Preston has the story
in Los Angeles it's fun and relaxing in
Washington DC mayor Muriel Bowser kicks
off the city's summer pool season and
thousands flock to Florida's beaches
Americans just want to be in the water
they try to rush me out because they
know the faster we get here the more
they get to be in the pool but with
increased demand comes Danger New York
City is facing its worst lifeguard
shortage on record with roughly a third
of what it needs this summer and that's
despite a nine percent pay increase and
a sign-on bonus the more people that
come out the harder it is because
there's so many kids uh you know kids
get lost all the time kids run away so
yeah that's when the life cards really
happens
this situation is so critical Nationwide
that about half of the country's 309 000
public pools will be forced to close or
reduce hours according to the American
lifeguard Association it is more than
just a summer job lifeguards have a
unique advantage of letting people know
that there's danger and to stay out of
that danger Wyatt warneth who patrolled
some of Florida's beaches says your
chance of drowning in front of a
lifeguard is about one in 18 million
still with low salaries the lack of
qualified applicants and rigorous
testing it's tough to find lifeguards
our agency here requires about 50
lifeguards we only had two for tryout
The Lifeguard shortage could get worse
as summer months continue so many cities
are offering up incentives in Phoenix
for example lifeguards are getting three
thousand dollar bonuses
Colorado has announced a series of state
grants to help rectify the problem Jen's
Battle of johnstown's YMCA says they
received just over ten thousand dollars
so it'll help us train and recertify
current lifeguards and incoming
lifeguards it'll also help us train
lifeguard instructors and that's a big
piece of this is to get more staff
trained to teach more guards these funds
vital to smaller communities like hers
there's less people up here and so
attracting that entry-level lifeguard is
more challenging so we need more
resources
for CBS Saturday morning Elise Preston
Los Angeles
a three thousand dollar bonus that's a
nice I don't even think that'd be enough
to get some kids to sign up you'd hope
so but I mean it's a serious job and you
don't want to mess around should you
need that lifeguard to be able to help
you you want them properly trained and
you want them to have the ability to do
what they need to do it's tough training
I remember doing some of it when I was
younger you were a lifeguard I was not a
lifeguard but I did some of the training
for it before being a camp counselor
yeah my son was a lifeguard he took it
very seriously two two years running but
it is no joke yeah most of the time
you're in the heat
I mean the parents are only responsible
yeah